back up
three counter protesters are arrested
after chaos breaks out amidst a drag
show in Texas
it happened in Fort Worth on April 23rd
video shows anti-drag show protesters
across the street from the fort Brewery
and pizza where a drag show is being
held the protesters from a group called
protect Texas kids held signs one
reading drag shows aren't for kids
police say the protesters in a group of
counter protesters were being monitored
through City cameras at one point
officials say a counter protester later
identified as 20-year-old Samuel folks
pepper sprayed several anti-dread show
protesters after that officers attempted
to take him into custody hey buddy you
come with me real quick
he's going to come with us he's right
here
body camera video then shows another
counter protester later identified as 33
year old Christopher guillot appeared to
hit an officer over the head with an
umbrella
after that a struggle breaks out
[Applause]
bring the units over here
don't wait for that gun
later on officials say a third counter
protester later identified as
37-year-old Megan Grant attempted to
rush officers to get at both folks and
Geo fine
all three suspects were taken into
custody folks faces multiple charges
including four counts of assault bodily
injury evading arrest and resisting
arrest Geo is charged with assault on a
peace officer and interference with
public duties grants faces charges of
interference with public duties and
resisting arrest
[Applause]
sit up stand up
[Music]
a statement from the Fort Worth Police
Department reads in part quote our main
goal during any protest event is to
provide a safe environment that respects
all participants constitutional rights
while effectively maintaining public
peace and Order however those who choose
to violate the law and assault others
will be arrested and charged no members
of the protect Texas kids organization
were arrested in the event Fort Worth
Police say it is now under investigation
to determine whether officers use of
force was justified reporting for a long
crime Network I'm Sierra Gillespie